hey what's up guys mkbhd here in the
last video when i said i was taking a
look at a pretty special gadget i wasn't
kidding this is the night vision watch
from tokyo flash who's apparently pretty
popular already now i've never been a
watch person and i'm guessing you aren't
either because after all you can just
whip your phone out your pocket and tell
what time it is but there's something
special about this watch that makes it
worth having more than a regular watch
but we'll get to that in a second the
design of this watch or i guess what we
could call the hardware is absolutely
rock solid literally this thing is built
like a tank it has a completely metal
exterior so water resistant up to three
meters glass face metal links it's all
embossed you can barely even scratch
this thing and also i can take a side
step and say this looks classy like
formal attire classy i think but
seriously that hexagon that glass
so good looking but the real magic
happens when you turn the watch on you
ready boom just look at it look at that
dang
okay wait wait wait hold your horses
let's take a second look it's actually
really simple check this out around the
outside of the watch there are 12 bars
one for each hour on the clock so the
third one is blinking it's the third
hour the leds in the middle indicate the
minutes 18 minutes so it's 318 no math
required
now it's a lot friendlier doesn't it
doesn't look great
yeah i thought so now if you look
carefully there are actually two buttons
on the side of the watch the top one
tells you the time and then there's this
bottom one and when you press the bottom
one it'll display the date the same way
12 bars for the 12 months and the middle
leds are the day of the week so there
you go now you know what day i'm making
this video so now you've got enough
practice you should be able to tell the
time at a glance right so here's your
practice ready
yeah did you get it let me know if you
can tell the time in the comments
section below now this watch is
obviously battery powered but it's a
rechargeable battery so you can recharge
it by this small port on the bottom left
and there's an included usb cable to
power it up and the battery lasts about
a month per charge so it's pretty good
and it can have a raging party with your
microwave so you know you're in business
so there it is guys this is the night
vision watch if you have anything more
to say you can use that comment box
below the links are in the description
enjoy your crazy variety of watches to
choose from and i will talk to you guys
in the next video thanks for watching
thanks for rating peace
[Music]
you